it is really getting bad for Trump's
lawyer Michael Cohen I actually almost
like 1% started feeling slightly bad for
him and then I realized really this is
all of his own doing and I stopped
feeling bad and realized there's people
in the world I actually should feel bad
for we've had a few weeks of quiet on
the Michael Cohen front no more quiet
it's now being reported that Michael
Cohen is losing his lawyers not that he
appears to have fired them but they
seemed to be quitting and he is likely
gonna flip and cooperate with
prosecutors Maga not make America great
again but as I've said before making
attorneys get attorneys and sometimes
losing those attorneys they are going to
be leaving Michael Cohen and to really
quickly catch you up cohen has been
Donald Trump's longtime personal
attorney he's the guy who set up the
hush money payment for stormy Daniels
he's the guy whose office condo in hotel
room were all raided by investigators
recently he's the guy who really seems
to be in a significant amount of trouble
and we were told he's never going to
abandon Donald Trump David Schwartz one
of his prior attorneys told megyn kelly
that his love for Trump is such that he
would never turn his back but he doesn't
seem to really have any other option at
this point he's been under criminal
investigation for months separate from
the Moller investigation there's a
totally separate case that he's involved
in in district court nearly four million
documents were seized as I told you he's
now under federal investigation without
legal representation because his lawyers
have bailed and there is every
expectation according to a recent ABC
news report and other corroborating
reports that he's going to flip and he's
going to be cooperating and this is a
disaster for the White House for
staffers for everybody the White House
is trying to downplay it they're
pretending that the district court case
doesn't have anything to do with Robert
Muller's investigation or with Donald
Trump which in some sense is sort of
technically true but clearly the guy is
in trouble
big picture and it's true that these are
separate cases but these are related to
Cohen's pattern of sketchy and
possibly criminal behavior in his work
as Donald Trump's attorney and also as a
confident for Donald Trump
if Trump has done anything illegal if
Trump has done it anything shady or
criminal as part of either his business
or his campaign the most likely person
to know about it and to have evidence of
it is Michael Cohen it's not Jared
Kushner
it's not gonna be Trump's own kids it's
this guy who has been Trump's confidant
for a long time and there is every
reason to believe that Cohen is flipping
and he's going to be working with
investigators and I want to urge you not
to take your eye off the ball because in
the last week we learned not only that
Michael Cohen is likely flipping and has
lost his attorneys but also that Trump's
campaign chairman Paul Manafort who had
already been indicted previously and was
on a supervised release he had new
indictments against him for allegedly
tampering with witnesses all in the last
week and because of North Korea and
everything else that's been going on it
hasn't made the news that it otherwise
might have made but this has been a
disastrous week for the Trump cabal
related to multiple criminal
investigations that are going on and I
want to say something that I don't want
taken as a joke or a satire especially
in light of Anthony Bourdain's suicide
and our story on suicide earlier this
week Michael Cohen should be on suicide
watch and I'm not being facetious I'm
being a hundred percent serious here
because this is so bad and Cohen doesn't
strike me as the type of guy to just
kind of go peacefully to prison if
that's going to be his fate the options
now are flip and cooperate make a deal
for yourself right self-preservation to
the extent that you can fight this all
the way to the end which would be
stunningly expensive probably disastrous
for Cowen's family or suicide and again
I'm not like I'm not being satirical you
know Pat that I don't make light of
suicide like suicides a really serious
thing and I'm not saying this inning Joe
'king way I think that this is a guy who
should be on suicide watch right now
yeah it's hard to read into in a sense
because we don't know if he has
depression or suicidal tendencies to
begin with but it seems like everyone's
bailing on
himright Trump's not gonna have his back
for too much longer now his lawyers are
getting out I think that's a reasonable
concern let's go back to the lawyer
thing okay if you're an attorney and
Michael Cohen hires you you are
immediately part of what will likely end
up being a historic legal battle in
American history right it involves the
president it involves foreign countries
and involves the limits of executive
power words like espionage and treason
are being thrown around and even just
representing Michael Cohen you've got an
opportunity to make a career for
yourself out of representing Michael
Cohen and you quit so something serious
is going on that would make attorney
straight-up quit it's either because
could be Michael Cohen can't be dealt
with right the guy won't tell you the
truth or he won't shut up when you tell
him to shut up or whatever or you quit
because you realize you have no chance
at defending the guy based on what he's
done or maybe there's some strategy here
okay so there's one possibility which is
that if your attorneys quit or you fire
them sometimes a court will allow you to
delay trial because you've just lost
your attorneys you need new attorneys
you need to get them up to speed so on
and so forth is it possible that there
is that element of strategy I don't
think that's what's going on but just to
be thorough that's the one way in which
Trump's Cohen's attorneys bailing could
be a strategy one more possibility
Michael Cohen's out of money right I
mean we joke about how he had to
personally pay for the hundred thirty
thousand dollar hush payment yeah you
know the guy's an attorney so you think
he's somewhat affluent but those costs
are going to you know stack up
eventually if you're against Robert
Miller but millions of dollars from
those sweetheart lobbying deals but yeah
we don't actually know how much of that
money does he still have how much of a
legal bill has the guy already racked up
either way it is really really bad for
Michael Cohen and the trend of lawyers
quitting or refusing to represent people
is becoming increasingly common in the
Trump world countless lawyers at this
point either declined to represent
Donald Trump in the Russia scandal or
agreed to initially and then they quit
after not that long and now Michael
Cohen is suffering the exact same fate
and if you're waiting around for Donald
Trump to come to his defense
oh no the Trump campaigns
discredit smear campaign against Cohen
is starting up and that's what I want to
talk about next